[Music]
they also wanted the animated characters
to really feel like their place in the
environment it's interesting seeing
cartoon animation that's not disney
based it's not warner brothers based and
by the way that's a different style than
the pixar storyboarding style
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video stick around at the end to see how
you can get a free 30-day trial
hey you hey what's up welcome back to
another episode of animators react we
got eric koenig on the couch today with
us eric has brought a bunch of really
cool old school animation we're gonna be
looking at the directing behind cartoons
i'm really curious to see your insights
into how directors through the ages have
done animation
so let's jump into it
so we're looking lord of the rings in
the hobbit not the peter jackson films
the og lord of the rings oh wait hold on
though like strider in the corner with
like the the hood over his head like it
has the same feel from the live-action
movies it does and it's a real tribute
to ralph bakshi the director he invented
a lot of this style and peter jackson
then kindly say paying homage to this
movie quite a bit my name is mr
underhill after your performance tonight
it won't matter what you call yourself
this movie uses a technique that's
called rotoscoping we've talked about
rotoscoping many times yeah our audience
is probably very familiar with what
rotoscoping is because we are very
familiar with what rotoscoping is
cutting out people it's very very
tedious but wait wait wait wait there's
no real people in this what's being
rotoscoped oh yeah yeah good point i'm
not seeing any any footage what's being
rotoscoped well so what they would do is
they would go out and film people and
then they would print out all the frames
of the footage and then the animators
would trace over the character problem
is you can't just trace things over
because you know humans we move around a
lot and we're not even quite aware that
we're moving around a lot so you can see
they're moving not like a normal cartoon
character yeah there's a little bit of
that extra kind of like weight shift
they're like hyper real with their
motion yeah what happened on this movie
is he was contracted to make one movie
out of all three books but he ran out of
time and ran out of money and so he gets
through the two towers and then the
movie just stops
right yeah i also distinctly remember in
this movie there were moments where it
actually looked like there were real
photographed people in it
so that's real footage that that
straight up just looks like real footage
you know that's just real this is that
is real people in weird costumes on
horses and then they painted it and they
did some compositing it's a very
distinct style though part of me wonders
like it's kind of weird and janky
because they're running out of time but
what if they just leaned into it and
accepted and embraced this style would
they have been able to actually finish
the whole movie cinematically it is
telling pretty much the same story as
the peter jackson version and ralph
bakshi did it you know there's props to
him he made lord of the rings so along
comes rankin and bass who's most famous
for rudolph the red-nosed reindeer and
frosty the snowman they get contracted
to make the
hobbit baggins
uh yes
i am looking to hire a burglar what
peter jackson took if you watch the
extended editions eight hours they
smished it down to half an hour and it's
a thousand times better i'm sorry the
original hobbit animated hobbit is just
a better movie
there's smog you know and he's much more
of a character than the metadata version
you know and his voice is a is a better
cast voice there's very little animation
but he's scary
[Music]
it's interesting seeing cartoon
animation that's not disney based it's
not warner brothers based you know i'm
not used to seeing dragons drawn like
that i'm not used to seeing cartoon
hobbits drawn like this yeah dude that
dragon looks like a freaking bear pelt
that's the beauty of animation it's
anything you imagine and at its purest
it's being used to tell a story that you
can't tell in any other medium i do feel
like that's something that you lose a
little bit when you like if you heavily
rotoscope people for your animation and
it's just okay i got the footage and i
just traced over it it's like cool
you're kind of just a human photoshop
filter versus like bringing imagination
to it and portraying images that don't
exist in real life and taking it a step
further well yeah and there's that i
think robert zemeckis was trying to make
a few films with that kind of motion
capture the polar express polar express
which i believe you guys have talked
about and the polar express could have
been a much better movie if they just
traditionally animated it yeah if you're
trying to make it look like live action
just film it in live action it's not to
say you can't rotoscope things make them
cool i mean a scanner darkly is not
trying to look real
no it's
its own distinct style and again there
is really good examples of motion
capture thanos is brilliant you know and
is totally taking advantage of the actor
and combining it with the animation and
it's it's incredible going back to
warner brothers a brilliant animator
named richard williams got the
opportunity to make a fairly famous
movie called who framed roger wrap oh no
way okay
[Music]
you know the idea of combining live
action and animation together had been
done you know before you know all the
way back to the very beginning of
animation but also in most famously in
things like mary poppins and whatnot but
robert zemeckis wanted to move the
camera he wanted to make a movie that
played as a movie first and then
combined the animation so it was a real
technical wizardry of both the brilliant
animation of richard williams and the
technical widgetry of ilm
they also wanted the animated characters
to really feel like they're placed in
the environment which is a little bit
different than like if you look at mary
poppins where the characters are flat
you know opaqueness shading in this case
there's smoke in the bar so they added a
layer of smoke over the characters in
the compositing layer so that they
really feel like in the environment like
they're actually matching the black
levels the penguins in the background
their black levels match the black
levels of the people's clothes around
them so it's like they're actually there
and being filmed through the camera lens
they really wanted to combine both the
practical elements with the animated
characters so that penguins are holding
real trays or in the case of this those
are real pianos so they had to really
carefully plan this whole sequence out
so that when they got to the animation
they knew exactly what they were doing
so we actually took a look at this scene
on an episode of visual effects artists
react so we've already broken down the
technical aspects of how you would
actually merge these things together but
it's really interesting to see what
you're talking about with the shading
and the intent behind how you would
actually animate these characters here
the other thing that richard williams is
famous for and capitalized on even
before doing roger rabbit is he loved
the real fluidity of animation on ones
so the idea of you know there's 24
frames a second
it's expensive yeah let's say you're
just instantly doubling your workload
yeah in the case of this it is needed
because the mixing of the live action
because live action moves on ones but in
traditional animation it's generally not
needed unless the character is doing
some kind of real fast motion but it was
really his style the famous project that
he was working on on the side is called
the thief and the cobbler it's this film
that he worked on for over 27 years we
talk about an artist that gets so buried
in the details well if you watch this
movie every detail is
perfect once upon a time there was a
golden city in the center of the golden
city the top this is wow that's hand
drawn this is hand drawn that looks like
a 3d model he's just orbiting a 3d model
he's like he's got his viewport and he's
just like orbiting around but you know
just that's so much work this is insane
yeah a shot like that so a normal piece
of animation paper is about this big
it's called 16 field it's about this big
that scene was drawn on pieces of paper
bigger than this couch wow i can't even
imagine trying to like you know how you
like all the papers yeah exactly yeah i
don't know they must have taken like
three people just to flip the animation
what ended up happening is is that
warner brothers agreed to fund the
completion of this movie he signed a
completion bond which basically says you
have two years to finish the movie
otherwise we take it away from you
and he couldn't let it go he couldn't
finish and so warner brothers took it
away to finish it and it came out under
a different title i think it's arabian
nights or something like that and they
hacked out the last bit of the animation
and they ruined his his genius
what i would say is
it's really cool but why yeah is the
probably six months it took to do that
shot worth not getting to tell your
story no not at all it is good to have
constraints yeah you know they work you
then have to use your imagination in the
constraints and find a more effective
way of dollying up to those three bold
balls you know talking about getting
carried away it calls to mind redline
someone's having doubts huh
hell i'm just trying to keep this thing
interesting this looks like something
that would be in love death and robots
to be honest
[Laughter]
we talked about this with the cure you
know japanese animators are i think it
comes from their penmanship when they're
young and they have this discipline
they're just brilliant artists
if i was just going to talk about the
cleanup with the real thick lines and
the black tone to animate a character
and have them move around but to keep
all of that consistent is a huge amount
of work yeah you're not just doing lines
and coloring you're also now doing
shading as an additional step right for
every single frame yeah and it has to be
exact because if the the little shape
under his nose or you know between his
cheeks is not exact it'll start warbling
i mean yeah i've been there with trying
to fix warbling issues whether from
rotoscoping or trying to track something
in or trying to paint something in and
you hit play and it's like
no
it took them seven years to make the
film and i believe it bankrupted the
studio in the process it goes into that
realm of like labor of love and life's
passion is that worth more than money
and time but at the same time it takes
money and time to make these things it's
not just one person doing it either you
know there's teams and there's companies
at stake as well and where do those
constraints lie because at the end of
the day you know redline is a visual
feast but to what end does it serve
there's a lot more to be said on redline
we'll do another episode where we go
into it we just it was great to touch
upon it here but don't worry for all
your online plans out there we'll
definitely do more
to all the kevin's out there who
subscribed after we asked you to thank
you kevin matt it's your turn
brad bird is pretty close to a current
day household name of a director in
animation he's a real student of film
real passionate about it his first job
actually he developed the idea of this
short it's called family dog
do you like what you see
you have to understand at the time like
none of these ideas of lights you know
and really imaginative animation very
cinematic it's you know he's combining
his love of disney and his love of
things like warner brothers and he's
he's mirroring them together the
original designs for this were done by a
young tim burton he was a guy you know
he steeped in like edward gory and kind
of thought out of the box and you know
didn't think like a traditional
animation designer and he brought a lot
of new life into this
because he was just such a student of
live action he had a great desire to
also get into live action and i think
there was always this idea that getting
into live action is more legitimate than
doing animation but to me
animation is the ultimate art form it's
the art form that encompasses all art
form there's a perception that it's for
little children but it's not for little
children you just showed a clip from red
line that's not for little children
you know and when you have a brilliant
director like brad bird i greedily don't
want him to do anything but make
animated movies and so fortunately
the next thing he did was a movie called
iron giant at warner brothers it's still
alive
shoot at it
this is early cg days you know around
the same time as toy story so he
championed the giant is the cg element
and then you've got brilliant character
animation you know this is an incredibly
cinematic movie it's very little that's
different than how it would have been
shot if it were live action
[Music]
let's get movies of here brad's thing
was he likes to really lock down the
storyboards when you watch the story
reel for iron giant it looks like the
movie just in black and white they were
able to get this incredibly beautiful
movie for way less amount of money
because everything is just really
thought out yeah the process is always
easier when the vision is very clear
going into it arguably emotionally you
should be able to walk away from that
feeling exactly how you would if you
watch the actual movie they're just
going to add more polish to it by
actually rendering it out with their 3d
animation and by the way that's a
different style than the pixar
storyboarding style if you look at the
story reel for toy story it was less
about figuring out every single
character beat every camera angle and
every bit of staging and lighting they
are just working on the character it's a
different style of filmmaking this is
john lasseter's style of filmmaking as
opposed to brad bird he likes to push
the technicalities of animation and the
filmmaking of animation and he's taken
the art of animation into the future
[Music]
strange thing the old incredibles like i
actually haven't seen the original
incredibles i've seen incredibles 2.
you've never seen the original one i've
never seen the original the original is
great i thought clint didn't work here
anymore
yeah you can see the elements of the
original toy story and like the
animation the lighting the shading it's
all just like a little bit just a little
bit simpler you know toy story movies
are uh on a technical level are kind of
interesting to watch because we watch
toy story 1 it really looks dated now
toy story 1 looks like the animatic for
toy story 4.
i have some friends that worked on toy
story 3 and toy story 4 and i remember
they were battling that idea of like how
much do they update the technique but
they have to in the end all that really
matters is is it funny does it have
heart does it tell the story does it
connect with the audience and again
looking at the technical flaws of some
of the you know earlier pixar movies it
doesn't matter because this movie is
amazing the three of us are gonna notice
it but you know my wife
she's gonna punch me in the arm if i
mention anything
so i feel like a lot of our viewers have
that issue now where like they'll be
watching with their friends back well
you know the effects of this scene one
of the things they forgot about they're
like shut up yeah
seriously
that's right guys it's my favorite type
of sponsorship audible i get to talk
about a book that i listened to recently
that honestly was one of my favorites
project hail mary have you seen the
martian well the author of that story
created this one as well and i think
this one is even better so the story
basically starts out this dude wakes up
on a spaceship in another solar system
without any idea who he is or why he's
there but the story kind of unfolds with
two parallel stories one with him on the
spaceship and two as he's remembering
the context behind why he got there i
want to talk about some stuff in this
book so badly but even just mentioning
it would be a spoiler all i'm gonna say
is that the ending to this story was one
of the best endings i've ever
experienced
it was like it was so magical like it
was upsettingly good and you can listen
to it for free by simply going to the
link in the description or texting
quarter crew to 500-500 and their plus
catalog has gotten huge you can get
thousands of originals all just included
with your monthly membership plus as an
audible member you get one free credit
per month to spend on any audiobook you
want so you can get like really nice
expensive audiobooks and just spend your
monthly credit on it so it's like
getting an expensive book for 15 bucks
so again just text quarter crew to 500
500 or even easier click that link in
the description you won't regret it it's
going to be great
but for now let's say goodbye to eric
matt
i see you over there matt you know i
actually have a lot of friends named
matt all of you you watching you're my
friends thank you for leaving a comment
down below suggesting what we take a
look at what the next animators react we
need some more cartoons to check out
i need your help thank you eric you
bring so much knowledge here in fact one
thing that i've tried to that i've been
inspired to do from you coming on the
show is you are always particular with
naming people who are involved in the
work that you're talking about i'm
striving to try to do more of that to
learn the names and say them out loud
yeah we can be a lot better about that
we tend to just like
oh someone did that
so thank you for not only sharing a
bunch of your knowledge with us but also
thank you for inspiring me to be a
better react host thank you thank you
both i i love this uh channel i love you
guys thank you so much thank you you
know as much as we geek out about this
stuff it's our job and we get to do this
for a living so i just can't thank you
enough for getting to come here and talk
about it you bet man it's it's an honor
and it's a privilege we're all very
fortunate and i love i love how many
people are clearly passionate about
these movies and shows that we are all
working on together in this industry
it's great to have someone come and be
like dude i love this scene this scene
blew my mind when i was a kid and it's
like yes we all have that kid inside of
us that that loved this stuff growing up
absolutely thanks for watching and we'll
see you next week